[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a
spectacular game that they just ended
from round seven of the tata still chess
tournament 2021 uh between uh 18 year
old russian grand master andrey sipenko
and world champion magnus carls and this
is their first ever encounter
and what an encounter it was uh so
without further ado uh let's check out
what happened as we we have a lot to
cover this game
so espanko has the white pieces and he
opens with
e4 uh we have c five by magnus he goes
for the sicilian
knight to f3 d6 and now d4 striking in
the center and again we will have a nice
knight of variation knight f6 knights to
c3
and a6 so the night of is on the board
and whenever
there's a neighborhood on the board the
most usual
uh options for white are bishop to e3
bishop g5 bishop e2 bishop to c4
but also just any other move but these
are the top four and
are you are most likely to encounter
them so here
not bishop to c4 which is the kind of
the the favorite but rather bishop to e2
we have e6 for magnus and now bishop to
e3 with bishop to e7 and this is where
the
fun starts already on move on move 7 the
the
top moves here are castles and f4 but
here uh espenko
goes for g4 and this is just wonderful
stuff
uh he's preparing to already start the
attack uh against
carlson's king preparing g5 and then the
pawns are just marching forward
so here carlson needs to decide what to
do uh he
could just block it with h6 but then
white would just continue f4 and
you don't really stop it this way so
magnus says uh i'm not gonna stop it i'm
just gonna
start pushing on the queen side which is
what you usually want to do
we have g5 attacking the knight on f6
knight f to d7
and now uh even a3 giving up the pawn on
g5 because
uh if you defend it then you allow b4
and this has been played before
but it's it's better for black after the
knight moves the bishop here now you and
now your e4 pawn is attacked and
uh white's attack kind of stops so here
after knight f37 we have a3
esc offers a pawn on g5 and magnus after
considering the position for sometime
decides to capture it with bishop
captures bishop captures
uh sorry uh bishop captures and now uh
after bishop captures and g5
we have queen to d2 uh so preparing the
capture on g5
uh and magnus decides to capture on e3
there is one game in the database where
bishop the e7 was played
uh but here magnus just captures an e3
and it is as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game
here we have queen captures on e3 and
magnus uh i guess being in the mindset
of
him being up upon decides to go for the
very aggressive uh queen to h4
now it's not an attacking move or
anything most likely uh
he wants to play g5 and then queen to a4
to trade off queens he's up a pawn so
uh why not and in fact white could even
allow this but it's very tricky for
example if white castles queenside
g5 uh then uh king to b1
not allowing this to come with a forced
queen trade
queen to f4 and now you can uh move away
queen to h3 queen h4 and then you go
queen to g2 and you keep the queens on
the board and now it's very very
dangerous for black
for example bishop to b7 you can play f4
but
this is uh if you don't have all of this
prepared it's very very hard to find
this over the board
uh queen captures rook h to f1 and it's
just a
a terrible terrible position for black
to play all of the lines are open the
king is still in the center of the board
very very hard to play uh but okay after
this queen to h4 move
uh esipenko decides he's not gonna allow
g5 so he goes rook to g1
first and now the queen and the rook
guard the g5 square and
also you're just attacking the g7 pawn
here so
magnus decides to defend it if you don't
defend it if you go for some tricky
ideas with the knight to e5
it's uh it's uh
crazy stuff will happen if rook captures
you can kind of trap the rook with the
knight to g6 but then
spinker would have knight to f5
defending the rook attacking the queen
offering the knight it's just a crazy
crazy position
and if this is accepted this comes with
check so
the black king is in check king to f8
now even
rook captures on f7 king captures
captures with
check and now after h captures uh queen
to f3 with
check picks up the rook and the white
will come out
on top so here after the king moves or
if you block with the bishop just queen
captures
and it's a tricky position as both white
and the black king are
quite loose but white will have the
upper hand here
so this is what exists in the position
so magnus not interested in allowing any
such complications
he goes g6 he just prevents the rook
from capturing on g7
and we have queen side castle from
esipenko and now magnus says all right
maybe this
queen to h4 move wasn't all that
impressive uh he just decides to
go back with the queen because it's not
easy to develop
if you castle it's probably going to be
too early uh
also uh rook to g5 will uh prevent the
queen from
entering the game for a very long time
so it's very dangerous to keep the queen
there
so queen back to e7 and now f4
and now uh okay uh black needs to needs
to decide what to do how to develop
white will always have a lot of options
he can go h
he can go f5 to bust open the position
and
black needs to do something about this
so here bishop to b7 by magnus
and now king to b1 it's uh always a
question whether or not to play this
prophylactic king to be one move
especially now when black doesn't have a
dark square bishop but
as ac pink plays it and it is the top
move
by the engine uh so of course uh this
also
in this position is justified and here
magnus
makes his first real mistake of the game
he goes knight to c6
which is usually a good idea but not in
this exact position
because of the move that was played some
three moves ago so feel free to pause
the video here and try to take advantage
of this
imprecision uh while i give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
so uh uh for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on
capturing on b5 as this is uh the
absolute best move and also you have to
spot that
at the end of this variation uh queen to
c3 will come with an attack on the rook
that's the point
g6 made this whole idea possible so here
knight c captures and b5 was played
magnus recaptured but now not
the usual knight captures on b5 but
rather uh
knight captures on c6 bishop captures
and now queen to c3 comes with a double
attack so that's
uh why that uh that knight captures on
b5 was so strong
and all made possible by this g6 move so
you can see how even such a
defensive move allowed the white to
attack so pretty crazy stuff
uh you know that can happen in chess so
magnus needs to decide what to do here
he decides to castle the safety he has
to give up uh but give
give back the piece queen captures on c6
and now uh magnus
has uh has a pretty bad position here uh
the d6 pawn is under attack
the b5 pawn is under attack f5 is coming
h4 h5 is coming this is just
very very uh straightforward stuff that
white can play so magnus decides to
mix it up a little bit he plays d5 with
the idea of
starting an attack on uh on the white
queen and on the white king he wants to
open up some lines play
bring the rook into the game and maybe
uh create
some sort of an attack here so e
captures on d5 and now
rook f the c8 but now again a very very
tricky position
where again you could pause the video
even pause the video here yeah and
try to find the absolute best move for
white again while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those who were able to do it
congratulations on
not grabbing the pawn on b5 and for
those of you who found the d6
this this is the move that gives white
absolute advantage
uh and this is what essipanko played so
anything other than that
is uh is just uh not not great but
of course this is the first move you
need to check and if you see that this
is all right
you don't even have to check the other
moves so this is what essipanko played
and now queen back to d8 the thing is if
you decide to trade here
rook captures and decaptures on e7 black
can immediately resign
because uh well the knight is under
attack
and you cannot move the knight because
of rook to d8 check uh
wins wins for white so here uh black
would have to play something like rook
to c7 but then bishop captures on b5
with a double attack on the knight
and we already said that the knight
cannot move that's just game after the
knight moves rook d8 to check and it's
game over
so instead of that uh of course after
this rook after c8
is pink played this d6 move attacked the
queen and now the queen moves
so queen to d8 uh and now now uh is
uh the question whether or not white
should now capture the b5 pawn
guys the queen is still under attack so
you you have to move it
and here uh esipenko played queen
captures on b5 and it's
it's all right to capture this pawn now
uh you'll see why
but uh there was a really really crazy
line but i'm not going to show it now as
for those of you who are interested i'm
going to return to this position at the
end of the video
there was a crazy supercomputer line uh
that i've seen on ancestry
uh the norwegian supercomputer that
follows all of carlson's games
at the depth i think 45 but we're gonna
we're gonna get back to that so here is
pengu played queen captures on b5 which
is perfectly
fine but it allows magnus sound counter
play along the b
file so here rook c the b8 and again
it seems like a very natural uh idea for
white to just bring back the queen
because you also want to defend against
rook captures on a3 so this kind of
makes sense
guarding the a3 pawn and it really uh
surprised me when esi penko was uh
thinking in this position for some seven
maybe seven to ten minutes and i
didn't understand why but then when he
played it then it was like oh
that's why so here esipengo did not go
for the
defensive queen to d3 rather he played
queen to c4 and this is the
uh this is the absolute best move in the
position point is
you allow rook captures on a3 because of
white's next move so rook captures on a3
was played by magnus
and now queen to c7 again uh with
with the with a lot of deadly threats of
course the the queens cannot be traded
if you allow this then of course just
pawn
captures and everything is under attack
here this is under attack this is under
attack this is under attack
uh of course this is instant resign so
here magnus has to figure out what to
play here and uh
in the game uh well in the game uh queen
the e8 was played but there are some
other very interesting options
for example can you go queen to f8 with
the idea of maybe delivering some sort
of a sneaky checkmate at the price of a
knight here
uh not really because after capture send
queen to g7
white has this defensive resource of
bishop to b5 and the attack is over
now there are even threats of capturing
this rook and after the rook moves
you just bring the other rook to help
out with the defense and it doesn't
matter it cannot be kicked away rook c5
everything is defended whites up a piece
a beautiful uh past
d6 pawn so completely winning
so that's what was in the position so
after this queen to c7 move
uh you cannot capture you don't really
gain anything by moving the queen here
so what can you do uh one option is also
rook to a5 uh we're just briefly gonna
discuss it
but after the queens get traded off
captures captures where it just starts
pushing b4 and now
uh white is up only one pawn but these
are three
pass pawns with the two connected pass
pawns on the bnc file so this is uh
a nightmare to try and play so instead
after queen
to c7 we said queen to e8 by magnus uh
it seems like the most resilient idea
and now comes
rook to g5 this rook is always needed
here because you want to trade off
at least a pair of rooks once you stop
black's attack the game is over because
those pass pawns are just
too fast for for black to stop so here
magnus
plays a very interesting rook to a4 he
he kind of
uh he kind of tried baiting uh
esipenko here into going bishop to b5
and it kind of looks
okay because the rook will be under
attack the knight will be under attack
twice
the problem is if you go for this then
magnus just goes for rook captures
rook captures and queen to a8 and all of
a sudden you're in a lot of trouble
checkmate is being threatened
uh if you go king c1 then just check
king here and now queen to g8 with
check picks up the rook on d1 king c3
rook captures here
and yes you can capture here but it's
just a very ugly position to play your
king is on c3
this game would would be over very
quickly
so instead after rook day four we have
rook to a5
s pencil now just offers the rook trade
like we said once you trade off a pair
of rooks uh black doesn't really have
any attacking resources left
so here uh we have rook eight to b4
magnus of course declines this goes
after the
two pawn and b three now essipanko
defends it
and now again uh magnus needs a move he
goes back
rook four to b7 kicks away the white
queen and maybe you could go something
like rook to c8 to
shift the attention to the c file uh and
here
queen to c3 so uh like uh
someone uh i i think peter lecko
mentioned in the in the
uh official uh uh commentary booth that
uh if this position was played by anyone
other than carlson with the black pieces
that no one would even be interested in
this game
because it's impossible to hold this but
as it is carlson it will be very
interesting to see
if if maybe he can hold this so here
carlson tries
reactivating the queen we have queen to
d8
and now again here comes a beautiful
beautiful move
uh bishop to f3 just attacking that rook
on b7
i'm just going to show a fun line that
starts with f5
but it's a very forcing line that that
kind of is forcing but also isn't
because after e
captures and rook captures uh if you
capture the rook then just rook g1 check
and it's game over
king to f8 to just queen to h8 this is
checkmate the pawn covers d7 square
uh the problem is after this uh e
captures on f5 and rook captures on f5
black doesn't have to actually capture
the rook and then you have to
calculate a lot what what's happening
and and so on
so if uh nothing else was in the
position probably what essie panko would
play but esipenko went for the absolute
top engine move uh after this queen to
d8 that is
bishop to f3 uh he attacks the rook here
on b7 and the rook
cannot remain on the seventh rank you
have to move the
uh the rook from the seventh rank and
then queen is coming back to c7
yes that's that's what's happening so uh
rook to b4
and now queen to c7 so magnus cannot
afford a trade he goes queen to f6 now
gives up a knight here
uh for some attacking chances but of
course ac pink doesn't go for it
capturing the knight loses the game for
him right away just captures on b3
and after this captures captures
whatever king c2 queen to beat you will
be checkmate
so of course s pencil needs to avoid
this so after queen to f6 we have
rook a uh rook the a8 going back uh with
um not going back going forward with the
rook trying to
trade off a pair of rooks and now uh
this idea of course is not possible
because once you sacrifice here and
after
c captures you cannot capture because
the rook is pinned so
the same idea does not apply so after
rook to a8
magnus said okay we're gonna trade once
rook captures an a8 we have bishop
captures an a8
and now again magnus leaves the knight
hanging he goes queen to f5 again with a
very tricky idea
that if the knight is captured then the
rook can again capture on b3 because the
pawn is pinned
and after something like king to c1 then
you just go in queen f4
check rook to d2 and then whatever you
will
you will uh you will be able to win this
game even though white is up a piece it
doesn't matter black has the attack and
the king is wide open for example
uh queen eight checking g7 and now uh
well even the bishop uh uh
is defended now but white doesn't have a
very active move if you go for d7
then just queen to f1 with check and
that's it if you play rook to d1 then
rook to a1 check
and you lose or if you go king to b2
then of course the amazing queen the a1
checkmate is happening
so after queen to f5 uh we have king to
b2
a very very solid move uh uh
just uh saying that uh i i'm not in
russia
you're welcome to try and save your
knight i'm i'm just interested in
pushing this pawn and once you move the
knight at this pawn will win the game
instantly
so here again magnus needs to decide
what to do you cannot move the knight
the pawn just uh marches forward so here
uh magnus
went for rook to b5 uh again uh
trying to create some some chances uh
because
if the knight is captured then maybe uh
rook c5 he can go after the c2 pawn but
this is all very very unlikely
i think magnus uh was only playing uh to
reach time control here as it's moved 34
already so
me and ac pink was somewhat low on time
so maybe
that can work in his favor but other
than that
it doesn't seem very likely so here
magnus captured the knight there is no
better move in the position
uh sorry spangle captured the knight and
now rook the c5
just going after this pawn i will
briefly mention what happens if rook to
a5 with the idea that maybe you could
create some chances along the dark
squares
uh doesn't uh really work because queen
eight checking g7 just d7 and that's it
after queen to f6
check you have the c3 move and there is
no attack
for black here so after queen captures
on b7 magnus tried rook to c5 but again
a very calm
rook to see one by esi penco if you go
to d2 then queen
sorry if rook the d2 then queen can
capture and
you're kind of uh harassing this rook so
just rook to c1
white's entire focus is just getting
this past pawn up the board
so queen captures on f4 by magnus but
now queen eight
check uh we have king to g7 and now uh
d7
and here uh there's really nothing more
to be done
uh if uh queen to d4 uh with
check then there's just uh there's
always c3 and the rook here so
it was in this position after d7 was
played that
magnus carlsen world champion uh
resigned the game and
suffered his first loss uh i think his
last one was last year
against the angst of duda i think it was
in norway chess
uh could be wrong but i think i think
that was his
his last loss uh and now again suffers a
loss to 18 year old
russian grandmaster andres penco in a in
a well what can only be described as a
brilliant brilliant game
because i was also following uh cesa's
cis's analysis
because uh it's at the depth 45 i mean
it's amazing uh
it only follows some carlsen's games and
then if carlson uh
loses or wins or ends the game then it
starts following someone someone else
i think uh it it goes uh you know rating
uh
wise uh who it follows uh but yeah it's
just a joy to watch and when you see the
these crazy crazy uh lines that cesar is
showing
you're just oh come command that's
that's disgusting and
i will okay so here just to show you why
magnus resigned after let's say queen d4
check c3 and queen d2 check
just rook c2 and that's it uh there are
no moves you have to move the queen
white gets another queen into the game
and that's it
uh so i will now briefly for those of
you who are interested
return to that position where i
mentioned that there's a crazy line
happening after
queen to d8 uh we said that uh icy
penguin played queen captures on b5 but
i'm just gonna i'm not going to
overexplain it i'm just going to show it
because it's uh
what sesame was uh saying that it's uh
you know winning on the spot
and you will now see what winning on the
spot means for a super computer
so here uh queen to e4 not capturing the
pawn here
uh knight to f6 attacking the queen
queen to e5 and now knight back to d7
of course challenging the queen again
queen to d4
and now rook uh to b8 preparing to push
this pawn
we have rook to g5 going after the pawn
here and
now rook to a5 black defense so these
are
super computer moves we shall not
question them uh
queen to d2 attacking the rook here and
now h6
attacking rook for rook so here rogue
goes back rook to g3
rook to a6 uh gets out of harm's way
that puts pressure on the d6 pawn but
now
f5 opening up the attack towards the h6
pawn
we have e captures on f5 queen captures
on h6 and now queen to f6 you have to
guard against the checkmating ideas
so rook to h3 and now rook 8 to b6
now doubling up on the b file rook to d5
again just a very nice rook lift and
queen to g7 offering a queen trade
queen h4 queen back to f6 queen to h7
check
king to f8 and now queen to h6 with
check queen to g7
and now queen back to d2 again uh
declining the the queen trade
and here it seems that it's only a
matter of time before
white uh wins this pawn and then starts
advancing all the other pawns and
like i said if this pawn starts marching
forward it's over so this is how
sesame plays it out king g8 rook to b3
uh and now after queen to f8 uh a queen
to d4
so just uh putting more pressure queen
to g7 and now
queen to f4 we have b4 by black and now
of course
white does not want to open lines where
place a4
uh prepares that b5 square for the
bishop we have queen to f6
and now queen back to d2 so always
keeping an eye on that pawn
f4 black starts pushing the pass pawn
but now bishop to b5
just attacks that knight and like we
said if the knight moves it's a game
over so black tries some counter play
here with f3
but it's not enough bishop captures uh
we have rook to d8 attacking the bishop
but now just queen to d1
beautiful stuff uh going after the f3
pawn and it doesn't matter if f2 just
rook to f3
and that's it uh whatever black plays
there are no good moves here
captures capture through captures and
these seven queen captures on f2 and you
get
this endgame queen against rook and so
it's very very interesting what uh
uh what a super uh super engine line
looks like but
if you were wondering this is what uh
winning on the spot means for uh for a
super computer so just uh you know some
20 moves uh but yeah uh only uh for
those of you who are who were interested
in this uh this
is you know insane uh but yeah uh
after this uh like we said after this d7
move magnus resigned and a brilliant
brilliant victory
for young russian grandmaster who wins
his first ever classical game against
world champion magnus carlson
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank
luis medrano saul gulshan uh gregory
thomas daniel constanza and a mystery
person for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the tata
still
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day